wir verabschieden heute unseren
ehemaligen bundesminister ihren spaß und
begrüßen sein nachfolger im amt herr
minister lauterbach wegen der pandemie
müssen wird das kann leider im etwas
kleineren rahmen machen heute das hätte
einen größeren rahmen
verdient denn diese pandemie hat uns
großes abverlangt und ich denke ich
spreche da auch im namen der kolleginnen
und kollegen sie herr sparen haben ein
großes geleistet sie haben dieses land
durch diese pandemie geführt und sie
hätten sie hätten das land gerne aus der
pandemie herausgeführt
lauterbach sie übernehmen ein haus in
schwierigen zeiten dieses haus in
schwierigen zeiten aber das haus kann
krise
und weiß wie krise geht auf unseren
einsatz können sie sich verlassen ich
übergibt das wort an staatssekretär
steffen der eine rede hält herzlichen
dank
des von jens spahn ja vielen dank herr
kautz eigentlich haben sie alles schon
gesagt in kurzform um das so
auszudrücken sehr geehrter herr minister
sparen ich weiß das sagt man ab heute
nicht mehr aber ich habe mich noch nicht
ganz daran gewöhnen können deshalb sehen
sie es mir nach sehr geehrter herr
minister lauterbach sehr geehrte frau
parlamentarische staatssekretärin der
parlamentarische staatssekretär
liebe kolleginnen kollegen für mich als
amtschef ist es eine besondere ehre
heute diese amtsübergabe zu eröffnen und
einige einleitende worte zu ihnen zu
sprechen
und ich sage auch ganz bewusst dass in
dem das wir alle gemeinsam ihnen alles
erdenklich gute wünschen für die
nächsten jahre die kommen im sinne
unseres landes insofern herzlichen
glückwunsch zur heutigen ernennung und
das haus wie haag ausgesagt hat steht
komplett hinter ihnen und ist bereit mit
ihnen gemeinsam diese pandemie zu
bekämpfen und auch zu
beenden ich freue mich sehr so viele
kolleginnen kollegen heute auch hier zu
sehen ich freue mich vor allem auch dass
ich eine neue kollegin bekomme als
zweite staatssekretärin im
bundesministerium für gesundheit frau
antje draheim
wir konnten uns heute schon kurz
austauschen das ist eine kluge und gute
entwicklung die iren sparen und ich auch
angeregt haben weil die leitung spanne
in diesem haus so groß geworden ist ist
wir glauben es braucht einen zweiten
staatssekretär eine zweite
staatssekretärin man insofern glaube ich
ist das die absolut richtige
entscheidung für dieses haus insofern
auch an sie ein herzliches willkommen
und das haus freut sich auf sie und ich
selbst werde gerne darum hat mich
minister lauterbach auch gebeten noch
einige wochen hier im amt weiter machen
so dass wir dann in 20 22 einen
geordneten übergang hinbekommen ich
glaube das ist angebracht in dieser
krise und dazu stehe ich natürlich auch
gerne bereit und als minister sparen und
wir alle dieses haus dann übernommen
haben ich ein jahr später erst vor
zweieinhalb jahren hatten wir
zugegebenermaßen noch etwas weniger
turbulente zeiten und die turbulenz für
uns damals im jahr 2018 kam ins haus zum
teil natürlich durch den neuen minister
und wenn ich das so sagen darf herr
sparen ich glaube sie haben das prinzip
von benjamin britten
berücksichtigt rudern ist ja oder lernen
ist wie rudern gegen den strom sobald
man aufhört dann treibt man zurück und
ich sage dass es ein gutes bild aus dem
rudern weil wir auch sehr bekannte
ruderer hier heute unter uns haben dass
das sein motto war für jan sparen der
von anfang an gesagt hat ich muss dinge
modernisieren ich muss dinge
vorantreiben und das haus hat das
bereitwillig aufgenommen und sie
bestmöglich
unterstützt wenn ich das so ausdrücken
darf sie haben schon damals 2018 mehr
fortschritt gewagt für das
gesundheitswesen und das hat allen sehr
gut getan wir sind nicht am ende eines
prozesses wir sind mitten einen prozess
und dieser prozess muss weitergehen und
insofern war auch immer klar dass der
minister eine hohe taktzahl vorgegeben
hat wir haben auf monatsbasis
gesetzesentwürfe dem souverän im
deutschen bundestag vorgeschlagen frau
widmer weiß worüber ich rede wir waren
alle auch ein stückchen
leidgeplagt und immer wenn wir dachten
hier in diesem hause wir schaffen das
kam das nächste paket und wenn das
nächste paket abgearbeitet habe
festgestellt jetzt steht corona vor der
tür und dann haben wir uns auch immer
wieder gefragt schaffen wir das oder
schaffen wir das nicht bisher haben wir
das gut geschafft aber klar ist auch
dass diese herausforderungen jetzt an
sie übergeben werden und als dann corona
in der tat hier im bmg gemeistert werden
musste über lange lange monate da war
auch klar bevor wir den kollegen heute
haben hier ins haus geholt haben unser
corona general war von anfang an der
minister und er hat entscheidungen
getroffen so schnell wie ich das in der
vergangenheit kaum gesehen habe weil es
notwendig war geschwindigkeit zu machen
in dieser pandemie und insofern ein
dankeschön dafür dass sie so schnell und
so viel entschieden haben in dieser
kürze der zeit manchmal gar nicht
richtig zeit zu überlegen aber erst mal
notwendig diese entscheidungen zu
treffen und insofern erinnert mich
manchmal diese herausforderungen die wir
heute noch haben in dieser corona krise
an die erkenntnis wofür in dieser woche
der italienische physiker georgia
parisien den physik nobelpreis bekommen
hat er hatte nämlich dafür bekommen das
ist in der physik manchmal einfache
probleme gibt die komplexe lösungen
haben und das ist glaube ich in dieser
pandemie auch ein bisschen so das
einfache problem dass wir kontakt
beschränkungen oder abstand einhalten
müssen zwischen menschen damit das virus
nicht überspringt erfordert komplexeste
lösungen weil in unserer gesellschaft
das nicht so einfach ist den menschen
voneinander abzuhalten vom kontakt
abzuhalten und das ist glaube ich auch
heute noch die echte herausforderung für
einfache probleme
komplexer lösungen zu finden und auch
tatsächlich umzusetzen und deshalb der
minister laut aber auch diese einfachen
probleme sind jetzt ihre probleme sind
jetzt unsere probleme und deshalb habe
ich mir jetzt lange überlegt was gibt
man eine minister mit auf den weg der
einfache probleme aber durchaus sehr
harte und dicke nüsse zu knacken hat sie
brauchen einen instrumentenkasten der
ihnen ermöglicht sehr harte und die
kulisse zu knacken ich erlaube mir mal
dafür das bestmögliche instrument mit
auf den weg zu geben
nämlich einen nussknacker aus deutscher
produktion
und ich sage ihnen ich habe lange
gesucht ich habe den härtesten und
größten müsse in ganz berlin dazu
ausgesucht und ich überreiche das gern
es ist alles desinfiziert und
zu achten auch die hygiene auflagen des
srk jeder können sie sicher sein wenn
ich das gleich tun darf
dann schließt sich direkt an mit dem
hinweis dass ich eigentlich auch gerne
meine ehemaligen minister ebenfalls ein
nussknacker geschenkt hätte weil er jede
menge müsse in der vergangenheit knacken
musste und sicherlich auch in der
zukunft noch knacken wird ich würde
trotzdem gerne ersparen davon absehen
und ich erkläre auch gerne warum ich
glaube dass ein neuer minister diese
harten nüsse nur knacken wird können
zusammen mit dem haus und deshalb
verdient nicht der ehemalige minister
sondern das bmg den zweiten muss knacker
weil der minister alleine diese müsse
nicht wird meistern können deshalb
erlaube ich mir auch
dem bmg und allen kolleginnen und
kollegen einen zweiten acker zu
dezimieren
und zwar einen berliner feuerwehr meine
damen und herren wir sind wir haben
übergabe in die wohnung des
gesundheitsministerium wertigkeit monate
ausgezahlt karl lauterbach hat schon
einen bekommen müssen dazu jens spahn
bekommt einen wir sehen das an diesem
nachmittag jedes ministerium macht die
amtsübergabe nach seinem eigenen gusto
und ich hoffe dass jetzt gleich so wie
sie anderen auch gemacht haben der
bisherige minister jens spahn spricht
von der cdu und danach der
amtsnachfolger
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ja also wie gesagt das ist
die amtsübergabe in berlin im
bundesgesundheits und
knacker aus deutscher produktion ich
nehme mal an sie kommen vielleicht auf
dem erzgebirge
aus dass zur verfügung steht und sie
aktiv unterstützen wird lassen sie mich
noch mal ganz gern von fallujah
ballistik grad noch sehe hier in unserem
fenster was man nach berlin aufgenommen
ein bisschen sparen ländern kommt und
dran ist mit seinem redebeitrag jens
spahn wie wird denn für ihn weitergehen
was plan der denn in zukunft
zunächst ist er bundestagsabgeordneter
und das wird er sicherlich auch bleiben
die frage die man sich vorstellen kann
ist bleibt er das auch über ein jahr
hinaus oder wechselt er dann wie seine
beiden vorgänger im amt des
gesundheitsministers irgendwann rüber in
die wirtschaft haben wir vielleicht auch
gelesen dass er sich ein ziemlich teures
haus zugelegt hat und ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass da auch die finanzen
drücken und es gibt durchaus die
überlegung dass sie entspannen dann
eines tages in die wirtschaft abwandern
wird kontakte hatte er genügend er muss
halt nur dieses jahr dazwischen
verbringen und in diesem jahr wird ja
auch weil sie darauf anspielen natürlich
die entscheidung in der cdu fallen wer
dort neuer vorsitzender wird und jens
spahn von einem jahr noch der
beliebteste deutsche politiker
ist mittlerweile ein bisschen
durchgereicht worden ob da noch platz
für ihn ist das wage ich doch zu
bezweifeln jetzt kriegt also hier
lauterbach seinen nussknacker von dr
thomas steffen das ist der
staatssekretär im gesundheitsministerium
die auch noch einmal gesagt hat dass
auch der scheidende minister eigentlich
so einen verdient hätte aber er hat dem
land noch keinen gegeben und jetzt
sparen
sehr geehrter herr minister lauterbach
meine damen und herren staatssekretäre
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren als sich
am 14 märz 2018 hier mit hermann gröhe
stand um das amt von ihm zu übernehmen
waren herdenimmunität
aero sohle kreuz impfungen selbst das
wort pandemie worte die vor allem nur
experten kann heute kennt das ganze land
diese worte was wir selbst war fast zwei
jahren erleben nicht nur in deutschland
sondern weltweit das war damals die
allermeisten unvorstellbar die
amtsübergabe heute spiegelt wider was
sich verändert hat es werden keine hände
geschüttelt sondern abstand gehalten und
masken getragen
und normalerweise kann ein neuer
gesundheitsminister auf eine phase der
einarbeitung eine kurze schonfrist
hoffen normal ist aber gerade gar nichts
wir befinden uns in einer nationalen
notlage wie wir sie seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg nicht mehr erlebt haben
wahrscheinlich
fand noch keine amtsübergabe hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit unter
so schwierigen bedingungen statt
in der aktuellen lage steht dieses
ministerium mehr im fokus denn je die
mutationen des virus zeigen wir sind
noch mitten in der pandemie
daher ist es gut dass diese zeit des
übergangs zwischen zwei regierungen nun
vorbei ist dass mein nachfolger heute
übernimmt
das gesundheitsressort traditionell
nicht zu den ressorts wie glanz und
gloria für den amtsinhaber
versprechen viel feind wenig er oder wie
eine unserer vorgängerin ulla schmidt
mal sagte als gesundheitsminister hat
man schnell die torten im gesicht
in den vergangenen dreieinhalb jahren
durfte ich aber erleben es ist ein
schönes ein
wichtiges ressort so habe ich es immer
gesehen das sage ich ganz bewusst auch
in dieser situation ich beschäftige mich
seit fast 20 jahren mit
gesundheitspolitik ich habe es immer als
große und sinnstiftende aufgabe
empfunden
für die gesundheitsversorgung von über
80 millionen bürgerinnen und bürgern zu
kämpfen jeden tag zu arbeiten ein
unterschied zu machen in ihrem alltag
mit dem was wir hier entscheiden und
anstoßen und ebenso auch mich für gute
arbeitsbedingungen für die mehr als fünf
millionen
menschen einzusetzen die jeden tag bei
uns im gesundheitswesen arbeiten
meine zeit unsere zeit hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit war
eine intensive zeit
schon vor der pandemie fast im
monatstakt haben wir hier im haus
gesetze gemacht
und nun seit zwei jahren haben wir in
einem ausnahmezustand agiert
wir haben wichtige modernisierung
angestoßen vor allem in der
digitalisierung und sie kommen nun
endlich auch im versorgungsalltag an wir
haben hier viele verkrustungen
aufgebrochen und die pandemie hat uns
gezeigt wie wichtig das gehört in diesem
bereich ist und ohne frage das ist ja
auch das vorhaben müssen wir diesen weg
weitergehen
auch in der pflege haben wir viel bewegt
im übrigen auch gemeinsam in der großen
koalition viel bewegt die herausnahme
der pflege aus den fallpauschalen
bessere bezahlung mehr stellen
die auswirke auswirkungen der
jahrzehntelang strukturellen missachtung
dieses unverzichtbaren beruf ist sind
weiterhin spürbar aber die
abwärtsspirale
die konnten wir zumindest stoppen und
beginnen in die andere richtung zu
drehen natürlich reicht das nicht reicht
das gerade angesichts der aktuellen
situation nicht die pflege bleibt eine
wenn ich die große aufgabe der 20er
jahre und
auch mit blick auf die aktuelle
situation was mich am meisten
erschüttert
das sind die erzählung von pflegekräften
auf intensivstationen die sich
buchstäblich aufreiben um das leben auch
von ungeimpften patienten mit 19 zu
retten die gleichzeitig dann nicht
selten den sinn dieser impfung
anzweifeln totale erschöpfung und
verzweiflung damit müssen pflegekräfte
wie ärztinnen und ärzte in diesem moment
oftmals ganz alleine klarkommen
so ich höre gerade doch sind wir wieder
drei jahren durch diese doch der ton
kommt wieder wir sind wieder in berlin
wenn wir nach und in dieser pandemie
nicht gelernt haben diesen beruf nicht
auch dauerhaft zur wertzuschätzen und im
übrigen damit auch dauerhaft summe zu
bezahlen und auszustatten wie es nötig
ist wenn du wäre uns tatsächlich nicht
mehr zu helfen
meine damen und herren mein besonderer
dank gilt allen kolleginnen und kollegen
hier im bundesministerium für gesundheit
und in den behörden unseres
geschäftsbereichs formal heißt
im robert koch institut dem
paul-ehrlich-institut
im bv und auch in der bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung ohne sie
werden all die vorhaben dieser
legislatur nicht möglich gewesen vom
staatssekretär bis zum sachbearbeiter
vom ministerbüro bis zur torte ich danke
ihnen für ihre loyalität
ihren unermüdlichen einsatz
ihre kompetenz und ihren teamgeist
es war ein gutes gefühl im team bmg als
teamleiter und als außenverteidiger
mitmachen zu dürfen
sie alle haben mir in schwierigen zeiten
mit rat und tat zur seite gestanden mich
unterstützt und nicht damit wissen
lassen dass wir an einem strang ziehen
und gerade in den letzten zwei jahren
war die arbeitsbelastung enorm
und diesem ministerium brannte bis spät
nachts das licht
schalteten sich mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter regelmäßig am wochenende zu
sitzungen zusammen
alles damit wir als land gut durch diese
pandemie kommen können ich möchte ihnen
ausdrücklich mein respekt und meine
anerkennung für ihre eindrucksvollen
leistungen und auch ihr
durchhaltevermögen aussprechen
und geben sie bitte diesen dank auch an
ihre familien weiter die diese belastung
mitgetragen haben
die wahrheit ist dass dieses ressort das
bundesministerium für gesundheit für
eine solche pandemie nicht ausgelegt war
dies ist eigentlich ein ministerium für
gesetzgebung
90 prozent wenn ich mehr dessen was wir
eigentlich tun dass gesetze machen
anders als ein innen oder ein
verteidigungsministerium verfügen wir
nicht wirklich über operative einheiten
und doch war in den letzten zwei jahren
der pandemie das operative im
vordergrund beatmungsgeräte masken tests
medikamente und eben stoffe beschaffen
mit den gesundheitsämtern der länder und
kommunen vor ort maßnahmen abstimmen
krisenstäbe gründen und leiten
in normalen zeiten würde man für jede
dieser aufgaben neue behörden oder neue
abteilungen gründen aber dafür war
schlecht keine zeit nur dank ihres
außergewöhnlichen einsatzes konnte es
überhaupt funktionieren und es hat ja
funktioniert das war es was zu beginn
knapp war ist nun mehr als genug da auch
impfstoffe gestern er es in brüssel beim
gesundheitsminister treffen sagte noch
ein beteiligter kollege zu mir ohne die
deutsche hartnäckigkeit im sommer
letzten jahres hätte es wahrscheinlich
ein vertrag der eu mit pfizer bayern
technisch gegeben wahrscheinlich
jedenfalls nicht rechtzeitig
auch läuft die aktuelle booster kampagne
und auch dort hat das ministerium alle
die jeden tag mit arbeiten in den
letzten zwei wochen noch mal ein
unterschied gemacht weiter gut an es ist
genug impfstoff da aktuell impft auch in
absoluten zahlen kein land der welt mehr
als deutschland zeigen sie mir einen
gesundheitswesen auf der welt das in
gleicher geschwindigkeit so schnell eine
solche impfkampagne so hochfahren können
sie herr lauterbach werden das gesetzte
ziel von 30 millionen impfungen bis
jahresende erreichen das ist gut für
unser land
eins ist mir besonders wichtig es ist
vieles gelungen
aber ich habe in dieser pandemie auch
manches falsch eingeschätzt auch fehler
gemacht
wir haben hier immer nach bestem wissen
und gewissen gehandelt und entschieden
wir hatten nicht das privileg
es im nachhinein doch schon vorher
gewusst zu haben
denn wir mussten in der situation
entscheiden und der großer unsicherheit
und mit vielen unwägbarkeiten
es war die bisher größte aufgabe meines
lebens mit allen höhen mit allen tiefen
und dennoch würde ich keinen tag
tauschen wollen
allerdings würde ich mit dem wissen von
heute manches anders entscheiden manches
anders kommunizieren ja bei der nächsten
pandemie wüsste ich manches besser zu
machen
ich habe letztes jahr im april gesagt
wir werden in ein paar monaten
wahrscheinlich viel einander verzeihen
müssen das geld damals das gilt heute
noch ich bin sicher das wird auch noch
in vielen monaten gelten
meine damen und herren aus den
erfahrungen des vergangenen jahres kann
ich sicher sagen die arbeit hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit ist
relevant für die geschicke unseres
landes unser ressort hat an bedeutung
hinzugewonnen und das wird bleiben
der bedeutungsgewinn spiegelt sich auch
in der personalentwicklung wieder lange
gehalten wir immer als kleines
zu meinem amtsantritt im märz 2010 hatte
das bundesministerium für gesundheit
rund 750 beschäftigte
heute haben wir weit über 1000 dieses
gewicht wird bleibt
der gesundheit wird einen anderen
stellenwert haben das ist eine lehre die
wir als gesellschaft aus der pandemie
ziehen müssen unser gesundheitswesen ist
mit blick auf die individuelle
gesundheitliche versorgung
hervorragend eines der besten der welt
in bezug auf katastrophenvorsorge und
öffentliche gesundheit müssen wir aber
besser werden an manchen stellen uns
auch neu aufstellen mit einem
aufgewerteten öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst mit einer nationalen
reserve gesundheitsschutz mit neuen
strukturen zwischen bund und ländern
dazu gehört das wäre ein neues
verständnis auch von krisenhaften lagen
entwickeln das von der gesamten
gesellschaft getragen wird
denn wir haben in dieser krise in der
öffentlichen debatte
diese krise nie wirklich als das
angenommen was sie ist eine
existenzielle herausforderung die uns
zwingt schnell zu reagieren immer der
lage angepasst
eine lage aber die sich beständig ändert
und dynamisch ist in debatten lässt sich
leicht abstrakt fordern vorausschauend
zu handeln
konkret ist das bei sich ständig
ändernden bedingungen manchmal schon was
anderes
wie beim minister lauterbach 2013 als
wir beide federführend den gesundheits
teil der damals werden in großen
koalition verhandelt hatten den damals
größten politischen streitpunkt übrigens
zwischen union und spd und das zur
überraschung der meisten auch noch
geräuschlos und erfolgreich da waren wir
beide fest davon überzeugt dass einer
von uns beiden gesundheitsminister würde
es kam anders
nun sind wir es doch beide geworden
hintereinander unter anderem trotz
anderen vielleicht sogar wegen der
anderen bedingungen
ein regierungswechsel ist eine zäsur es
ist ein neuanfang ich wünsche mir dass
dieser moment genutzt wird lassen sie
uns alle über die eigene haltung und die
eigenen argumente neu nachdenken den
kopf aus der eigenen babbel der eigenen
debatten blase hervorheben und breit
informieren
auch über die lage und die argumente
andersdenkender es ist jetzt
ein moment dazu denn es ist und bleibt
dabei die pandemie bekämpfung ist
gemeinschaftsaufgabe noch sind millionen
erwachsene nicht geimpft impfung
bedeutet zugleich selbstschutz und
schutz von mitmenschen wir haben es alle
zusammen in der hand dies also ist mein
letzter appell als scheidender
bundesminister für gesundheit
helfen sie alle mit dass die korona
politik gelingt dass die korona politik
auch meines nachfolgers von herr
minister lauterbach gelingt denn es geht
hier nicht um politische karrieren steht
so viel mehr auf dem spiel für unser
land für die bürgerinnen und bürger und
für deren gesundheit
in diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen lieber
minister lauterbach und ihrem team viel
kraft erfolg ausdauer und ich gratuliere
ihnen herzlich in allen wünsche ich
alles alles gute gesundheit und gottes
segen
diese zuschauer das waren die
abschiedsworte von
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen er
war persönlich sehr ergriffen er sagt es
war die schwerste aufgabe die größte
aufgabe seines lebens ihm versagte auch
an kurzen moment lang die stimme das war
also ein sehr emotionaler augenblick und
jetzt tun wir den neuen
bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren eben wurde
wie entspannt als minister sparen
angesprochen da hatte ich die hoffnung
er würde weitermachen denn zwei minister
kann das haus eigentlich gut brauchen
aber
trotzdem möchte ich hier also zunächst
einmal damit beginnen dass ich ganz was
ich einfach ganz herzlich danke sage wir
haben immer gut zusammengearbeitet es
war immer fair
es war immer in hass getrieben es war
nicht nur in der pan am über die vielen
jahre über die wir uns jetzt schon
kennen war es eigentlich immer unser
stil und dafür möchte ich einfach
schlicht ergreifend hier vor allen danke
sagen vielen dank herr spahn
ganz kurz so mir selbst an paar worte
zur einschätzung ich bin von der
herkunft und auch von der art und weise
die dinge anzugehen sehr stark also
wissenschaftlich geprägt ich bin selbst
arzt und
gesundheitswissenschaftler ich leite das
institut für gesundheitsökonomie und
klinische epidemiologie der uniklinik in
köln bin dort also bei urlaub und
komme aber aus diesem aus dieser
perspektive an die aufgabe heran das ist
wichtig weil also die gesundheitspolitik
aus meiner sicht kann nur dann
erfolgreich sein wenn sie sich in der
wissenschaft verankert findet in der
evidenzbasierten medizin das wird sehr
stark die art und weise bestimmen wie
ich an diese probleme die vor uns liegen
herangehen ich mich auch gleich sagen
was also aus meiner sicht für das haus
die wichtigste aufgabe ist die
wichtigste aufgabe für das haus ist die
pandemie für deutschland zu beenden und
der nussknacker den wir dafür verwenden
werden den habe ich heute mitgebracht
der ist quasi schon vor ihnen der
nussknacker ist das haus selbst wenn es
mit dem haus schaffen diese pandemie zu
ende zu bringen in den nächsten monaten
alles daran setzen mit der neuen
variante mit der nikon variante fertig
zu werden wir werden die booster
impfungen so schnell wie wir können
weiter in die fläche bringen wir werden
genau dort ansetzen wo
ex minister spanisch grad beschrieben
hat die 30 millionen impfungen bis zum
jahresende die werden wir verfolgen
werden impfstoff beschaffen um diese
erfolgreiche booster impfung kampagne in
die nächsten monate hineinzubringen und
wir werden dann in den monaten danach
mit neuen impfstoffen die auf die
omikron variante angepassten dieses werk
weiterführen wenn solange postern und
impfen bis wir die pandemie zu ende
gebracht haben das ist aus meiner sicht
die vordringlichste aufgabe die wir
haben die wir gemeinsam haben und ich
glaube dass wir das gemeinsam schaffen
wir
die
arbeit die geleistet worden ist ist eine
großartige arbeit war dass deutschland
ist durch die ersten drei wellen
therapie besser durchgekommen
als fast alle anderen europäischen
länder wir haben eine über sterblichkeit
von ungefähr 4 prozent die
vergleichbaren länder von der
altersstruktur vergleichbaren denn da
haben eine über sterblichkeit von acht
bis elf prozent
das ist auch der arbeit dieses hauses
und dass es auch ihre arbeit zu
verdanken dafür möchte ich mich ganz
herzlich bedanken und diese arbeit
möchten wir fortsetzen so dass wir
weiterhin auch im vergleich zu anderen
ländern besonders gut durch die pandemie
kommen wir haben im gesundheitssystem
zahlreiche aufgaben vor uns design mal
an gearbeitet sind aber die weiter
geführt werden müssen wir müssen die
pflege besser bezahlen wir müssen die
pflege besser ausstatten wir müssen zu
besseren pflege
personalschlüssel können wir müssen zu
den personalschlüssel kommen in einer
art und weise dass sie nicht durch das
bestehende system der fallpauschalen
wieder eingesammelt werden wir müssen in
der
pflegeversorgung der pflegeversicherung
müssen dazu eine situation kommen dass
der eigenanteil die familien nicht
bedrängt und in armut zwingt wir müssen
pflegebedarfs autoschlüssel auch in der
altenpflege umsetzen wir müssen in der
altenpflege dazu kommen dass die
pflegeleistung eine qualität hat dass
sie über das was wir bisher erreicht
haben hinausgehen müssen also in der
intensivmedizin die
versorgung so verbessern dass die
intensiv medizin nicht aus in eine
situation kommt dass sich in der cobit
versorgung auf der einen seite und der
versorgung von patienten mit anderen
erkrankungen eine abwägung getroffen
werden muss wir werden also in der
arzneimittelversorgung anreize schaffen
müssen dass die arzneimittelversorgung
dazu führt dass die forschung in
deutschland intensiviert wird
wir müssen also in der versorgung der
haus erst dazu kommen dass wir das also
vor uns liegende mangels system ein
hausärztlicher versorgung abfangen wo
wir es noch können wir brauchen dort
nicht mehr medizinstudierende und wir
müssen diese medizinstudierenden auch so
ausbilden dass sie in der versorgung
bleiben wollen und nicht in andere
bereiche abwandern wir haben also ein
portfolio von aufgaben vor uns die also
dringlichste aufgabe die bekämpfung der
pandemie aber auch das gesundheitssystem
so aufzuwerten dass es tatsächlich
zukunftssicher ist und auch menschen in
das system bringt denn wir werden
zunehmend probleme haben junge leute für
das für die gesundheitsversorgung zu
finden und auch in die
gesundheitsversorgung zu binden daher
bin ich froh dass wir hier als team
arbeiten werden ich lege allergrößten
wert auf teamarbeit ich werde sehr eng
auch also beispielsweise mit
dem personalrat ich werde sehr genau mit
der mitarbeitervertretungen arbeiten ich
werde sehr darauf aber darauf achten
dass wir genug personal vor ort haben
und ich bin dankbar dass wir ein teil
unseres teams heute schon vorstellen
können die beiden parlamentarischen
staatssekretäre
sabine dittmer und es kaffanke sind
schon da und konnte neben bereits
vereidigt werden ich bin stolz und froh
dass wir frau doktor anke drach als
staatssekretärin gewinnen konnten die
unser team verstärkt ich bin sehr
dankbar dass staatssekretär stephan hier
weiterarbeiten wird den ich darum
gebeten habe und dem ich dafür danken
durch da auch im namen von
bundeskanzlerin
ich informiert habe dass sie die
bereitschaft haben hier weiter für uns
zu arbeiten
wir werden auch weitere
personalentscheidungen in den nächsten
tagen treffen ich glaube auch dass wir
möglicherweise die leitungsebene des
hauses wieder in dieses zentrale haus
zurückführen so dass wir die nähe also
zum gesamten team haben aber ich glaube
dass wir gesandt also aufgebaut sind
aufgestellt sind für die aufgaben die
vor uns liegen und wie gesagt die also
bekämpfung der pandemie in den nächsten
monaten ist unser zentrale aufgabe wir
werden das schaffen
auch wir werden möglicherweise den einen
oder anderen fehler machen aber wir
werden nach vorne gehen und ich möchte
in diesem sinne noch einmal ganz
herzlich jens spahn für die geleistete
arbeit danken und möchte mich auch dafür
bedanken dass er sich bereit erklärt hat
bei dem ein oder anderen punkt noch mit
rat und tat zur seite zu stehen so haben
wir ja immer zusammengearbeitet und also
das freut mich auch dass wir beide dann
doch noch einmal gemischte minister
geworden sind nachdem wir es 2013
dem anderen jeweils gegönnt hätten aber
selbst davon ausgegangen sind dass wir
es werden und beides ist nicht eine
fällung nicht in erfüllung gegangen
somit also vielen dank an alle die heute
hier sind vielen dank an den nussknacker
für die großen aufgaben die vor uns
liegen und glückauf wir werden es
gemeinsam schaffen vielen dank
ja so warnt die amtsübergabe im
bundesgesundheitsministerium meine damen
und herren vielleicht gucken wir nach
ganz kurz zu meinem kollegen joachim von
verlor oder wir bleiben drauf ich guck
mal an die regie
ja wir gehen jetzt weiterzug der hat
joachim von fallois wir haben ja die
beiden statements der minister sparen
und und lauterbach gehört joachim also
es war dann doch sehr emotional bei jens
spahn als er den pflegekräften gedankt
hat und als er noch mal im angesichts
des ernstes der lage corona pandemie
gesagt hat das war die schwerste aufgabe
bisher in seinem leben stoppte ihn noch
kurz die stimme
ja das ist so entspannend 2002 den
deutschen bundestag gekommen seitdem
kenne ich ihn auch und es gilt nicht nur
für ihren sparen sondern für all diese
politiker die wichtigen entscheidungen
treffen müssen die aus dem fernsehen
bekannt sind das sind auch nur menschen
sag ich mal und diese pandemie hat allen
das maximale abverlangt auch das wissen
dass wir sparen schon sehr frühzeitig
geteilt hat das auch fehler vorkommen
werden und dass solche fehler event will
dann auch durchaus für den ein oder
anderen betroffenen zur katastrophe
werden kann in den masten fehlen oder
betten das ist jetzt sparen und anderen
politikern immer wieder bewusst und ich
glaube dass viele in der bevölkerung
einfach zu hart urteilen über politiker
die natürlich auch fehler machen auch
teilweise reihenweise fehler wo man sich
dann fragt warum muss das so sein
aber ich fand es sehr aufschlussreich
jens spahn wie gesagt hat ja noch einmal
darauf hingewiesen auf 2013 als man
damals spd und cdu/csu gemeinsam
verhandelt hat er mit karl lauterbach
und dann ist der minister den ich
übrigens vorhin vergessen habe der nicht
in die wirtschaft gegangen ist nämlich
hermann gröhe zunächst
gesundheitsminister geworden zur
verwunderung der beiden anderen und in
der tat es ist tatsächlich jetzt so dass
beide dann doch noch gesundheitsminister
waren oder jetzt geworden sind also so
schließt sich der kreis und vielleicht
kann man auch noch sagen dass der
jetzige minister etwas zu spät dran war
liegt auch an einer besonderheit die in
diesen minuten überall in den
ministerien stattfindet er hat nämlich
schon seine beiden
staatssekretäre vereidigt sabine dittmer
und edgar franke das sind zwei
bundestagsabgeordnete das sind die
parlamentarischen staatssekretäre und
dann ist immer von weiteren
staatssekretären die rede das sind sehr
wichtige leute sind die beamteten
staatssekretäre zunächst der steffen der
in diesem ministerium zunächst erhalten
bleibt von jens spahn ein mann und dann
antje draheim die auch eine ganz
interessante historie hat die war
nämlich lange jahre hier bevor ich diese
des landes mecklenburg vorpommern und
ist gerade erst vor einem monat
befördert worden als staatssekretärin
beim gesundheitsminister in mecklenburg
vorpommern da ist sie nicht lange
geblieben sondern ist gebeten worden
jetzt hier nach berlin zu wechseln also
so schnell kann es manchmal gehen ja das
ist ja das interessante an diesem
nachmittag bei den einzelnen
amtsübergabe dass der auch die
menschliche komponente wie wir es gerade
gesehen haben nicht zu kurz kommt herr
professor meyer politologe von der uni
in bonn wir haben auch karl lauterbach
reden hören er hat sehr viele
vorschusslorbeeren gekriegt nun muss er
zeigen was er wirklich auf dem kasten
hat und ist ja im prinzip schon das war
wie würden sie das dann beurteilen war
das schon seine erste rede als neuer
gesundheitsminister
jedenfalls die programmatik hat er ja
geäußert hatte verschiedene punkte
angegeben
pflegeintensiv medizin und so weiter
insofern in der tat war es ein portfolio
präsent und trägt er zum fortschritt der
gesamten
dass karl kabinetts mit seiner
programmatik bei und wo wir vorher
zweifel hatten ob er so von seiner art
auch ein ministerium leiten könnte hat
er innerhalb kürzester zeit eigentlich
hier uns beliefert mit mit einer der
sache die ihn umtreibt und er war
offensichtlich ja schon im ministerium
entsprechende aktiv mit der verwaltung
usw
insofern großen große eindruck den ihr
hier gemacht hat und wir könnten da
glaube ich sehr zufrieden sein mit
seinem mit seinem anfang